hello and welcome to the stanford gsb
partnership for diversity fellowship
webinar
my name is alison davis and i'm with mba
admissions
with me are two panelists who are former
recipients of the p4d fellowship
we have 45 minutes together and will be
focusing on your questions i hope you
all had a chance to read about the
fellowship in advance via the website
link that we sent you
to give you a brief overview p4d is a
fellowship that was created to support
diversity both at the gsb and in the
global business environment the
fellowship covers full tuition for the
two-year mba program for one student
annually the goal is to support students
with diverse perspectives broadly
defined
if you have a unique cultural personal
or professional background we encourage
you to apply
you can do so by submitting a
supplemental essay with your round one
or round two mba application and you'll
find the detailed instructions on the
website link that we sent you
after you're admitted to the mba program
we'll pass your materials along to the
fellowship's corporate sponsor who will
select the finalists to interview in may
you are selected on the basis of how
your background and experiences will
contribute to
diversity at the gsb
and beyond and we would expect that you
would hear if you had received the
fellowship
by june
the fellowship is currently sponsored by
eli lilly
prior to enrolling at the gsb
fellowship the fellowship recipient will
spend nine to 12 months interning at eli
lilly headquarters in indianapolis
where where you'll gain valuable
experiences working for a leading
pharmaceutical company while earning a
competitive pre-mba salary and benefit
please note that at this time u.s work
authorization is required to be a
candidate for the p4d fellowship
after you complete the internship you'll
matriculate to the gsb in the following
fall
after you graduate from the gsb there is
no obligation to return to eli lilly
and please know that if you aren't
selected for the fellowship and are
admitted to the mba program
we meet 100
of the financial need for each of our
admits through a combination of
fellowship and loans
so with that overview i'd like to go
ahead and introduce our panelists
so i'm going to start with
you tiffany if you could introduce
yourself and say a little bit about what
you were doing before stanford and a
little bit about what you're doing now
yeah sure so i actually graduated from
the gsb in 2013
i
received the benin fellowship in 2010
so i was working at eli lilly from 2010
to 2011 and matriculated to the gsb in
2011.
um but prior to the bini fellowship and
prior to the gsb i was actually working
in business strategy consulting
for bain and company i worked on a
variety of different projects did that
for about two and a half years
and then i just finished so after the
gsb i just finished an externship i was
basically like an interim business unit
manager at a company that helps families
locate senior housing raising loved ones
um did that for about six months um i'll
be returning to bain for about a couple
a couple years just to broaden my
consulting skill set and also to get
some more direct management experience
um for a little bit but my real passion
is to focus on an entrepreneurial
entrepreneurial endeavor that i've sort
of started recently so would hope to
pursue that over the next couple years
and build it out
and hopefully it'll be to a point where
i can pursue it full time after that
thank you laura
hello everyone my name is laura fallon i
am currently a first-year mba student or
an nba one at the gsb
directly before coming to
school i was working at ui lilly and
company in their marketing division as
part of the p4d
fellowship program
before being admitted to stanford i was
working at merck and company for three
years in
multiple different functional roles
across their manufacturing division
thank you laura what drew you to
applying for uh to apply for the p4d
fellowship
personally i was looking to
contrast my experience at merck in the
manufacturing division against
another
comparable big pharma
fortune 500 company as well as get the
contrasting experience from the
manufacturing division to see the
marketing side
okay and tiffany how about you what
attracted you to apply
yeah i was actually really looking for
another experience outside of consulting
that's sort of what i'd already done and
it was really
i guess attractive the idea of being
able to work inside of a company and see
what it's like to actually just be on
the inside making decisions
and i didn't mention the type of work
that i was doing there but i was working
in new product planning which is a
marketing role but it's a strategic
marketing role so the really good fit
was sort of what i was doing before but
still being able to get that
experience of being on the inside
okay tiffany can you say a little bit
more about the types of projects that
you did and were you able to request
the areas you wanted to work in how did
that work
yeah so so not really we didn't really
get the request um i think that's just
where they had an opening that that year
so then neuroscience
new product planning i do believe that
most of the fellowship recipients do go
into the marketing groups that's
typically where people go but within
marketing it's a big big group um and i
was i just happened to be in this really
really early phase area that was mostly
just strategy based so what that means
and what i was doing specifically was
looking at basically white space market
assessment so where are the areas that
eli lilly wasn't currently serving
and what would those opportunities look
like and where should they focus first
so
in terms of doing that there were some
market forecasts looking over
epidemiological data competitor
landscapes
highlighting the standards of care unmet
needs overall market threats and
opportunities things like that
to basically refine the areas or
recommendations as to where i thought
they should be looking in combination
with
what was the best fit given their
current portfolio
and were you in the same team for the
entire time or were you rotated around
the company
yeah no i was in the same team uh for
the for the whole time
okay
and laura how about you what kinds of
projects did you do
so i was in a
global marketing role within the women's
health division supporting osteoporosis
products and i was in the same team
for the full 10 months that i was there
however i had two
main projects throughout that time
and
i was assigned into the marketing role
however there was some flexibility in
terms of me being able to bring up to my
manager different development goals i
had or specific opportunities and
interests so they could try and work
within their scope of all the different
things they needed to accomplish what
would align best
with that for me and so my first project
was
really looking at performing a
competitive analysis looking at scenario
planning for a potential competitor that
was potentially going to enter the
market look at that contrasting against
an existing product and worked on that
for a couple months and then after that
the remainder the majority of my time i
was
focusing on the
global
high level brand plan
for
one of the companies blockbuster
products and so for that really
personally owned the development of that
brand plan from end to end
start to finish really looking at things
such as the competitive analysis i had
already done folding that in as well as
environmental
analysis
and really looking at customer insights
and then what would be the strategy and
also any tactics moving forward to
execute that and roll that out into the
specific countries afterwards
great
in your opinion would the fellowship be
a valuable experience if the person is
not interested in a career in healthcare
uh loris you could start please
well i would say absolutely
for me it just happened that my
background was already within healthcare
but i would say would be extremely
valuable for
a couple of different reasons
one i would say all the skills that i
picked up in terms of from a functional
perspective in terms of marketing and
brand planning and all those processes
would really be
applicable across industries whether
it's even just something as consumer
products or just
branding
or launching products period i think
that would be definitely applicable
also kind of as tiffany had mentioned i
think the
first hand industry experience is
extremely valuable if you're coming from
a background
maybe something more of a consulting
role or something with a support
function role i think having that
firsthand industry experience
has been extremely beneficial in terms
of going into the existing courses
at school and then also i think the
program was extremely valuable in terms
of making sure that i was working
closely with mentors throughout the
organization in terms of having
conversations about
soft skills leadership skills and
developing all of those which would of
course apply anywhere
and were those mentors that you sought
out or is it a more structured situation
where you were assigned mentors
so i
think it's kind of a combination i think
that the organization was extremely
mindful and purposeful in terms of
assigning
me as an individual to report to someone
who was not just operating as a boss who
was not just giving me projects but was
also someone who was mindful of my
personal development and as a manager in
that way
and then from there i think that the
culture within eli lilly is also one
that is extremely
focused on
making sure that everyone within the
company is developed and has a lot of
opportunities to network throughout the
company and have those mentoring
relationships
could you laura give an example of a
developmental goal
that you had for your time there and and
how you
worked on it during your your
internship
yeah absolutely so um
one
pretty tangible i would say soft skill
though was
being able to work on my
oral presentation skills my background
was in chemical engineering working in
the manufacturing division most of my
opportunities were a little bit more
hands-on or analytical at that point in
time and so i wanted to make sure that i
had some practice in that before coming
to the business school and so
my managers were
very focused on making sure that the
projects i had weren't just
resulting in a report that i would hand
in but were something that i would be
able to present to upper levels of
management
okay
and tiffany how about you do you think
this uh experience is worthwhile for
people who are not uh interested in a
career in healthcare
yeah absolutely i think going into it
healthcare was not necessarily
originally on my radar i was just
looking for something
that was relatable to me and originally
i was thinking something more consumer
goods in terms of like an ideal industry
but healthcare really resonated because
it is something that affects everyone's
life um very intimately and being able
to be early phase uh and do some of that
research i really got to see how much of
an impact a company like eli lilly can
make so it was something that became a
lot more attractive to me after i i kind
of got there and got started so yes i
definitely think um and even if even if
people didn't happen to have a specific
interest i think that the opportunity to
become more interested is definitely
there and i i would be surprised to see
if people even if they didn't originally
uh i guess appreciate the industry would
develop a really strong appreciation for
it once you really get to see how much
of it affects your life on a day to day
um and i agree with everything uh
everything else that laura mentioned
with regards to sort of transferable
skills
throughout regardless so that was all
good as well and um with regards to
mentoring and coaching i have similar
process as well my the skill sets that i
want to develop were a little bit more
broad i just wanted is more so about
exposure to me and so i got really
wanted to request a deep dive into
marketing so i tried to get exposure to
the various areas even outside of the
early new product
development area so and they they did
make those happen in terms of meeting
with people and getting getting to
shadow people
so i definitely got to uh you can make
the experience what you want okay
let's go on and answer some more
questions that were submitted um in
advance by
our callers our participants uh what
adolfo is asking uh when will the
internship start and it if you applied
this year and were accepted it would
start this coming summer
and then um you would enroll at stanford
in fall of 2015.
and uh adolf was also asking what
determines the length of the internship
that's really lilly's call so we'll know
by spring if it is going to be a full
12-month fellowship
or a nine month fellowship
and what what the term is going to be
our tour asked if there's obligation to
stay
with p4d um with
the corporate sponsor after your mba and
no actually that's what's really uh
quite an advantage is you there is no
obligation to return to the same
employer
we've got a couple of people raising
their hands so
let's call on noah
um i i am currently doing an mba
application so i'm doing a regular
application but i saw the question in
the application itself
which stated whether i was applying for
the p4d fellowship or not so if you
press yes by default it just asks you to
upload certain documents i know that one
of the
requisites is the p4d essay is there any
other requirements for the application
except for the p3d fellowship essay that
i have to upload in my in my application
to be eligible
right noah um there we'd also like you
to upload a resume as well as your
extracurricular activities and so those
three documents we'd like those uploaded
as one pdf
and we're going to try to go over to the
application right now and show you
what it what it looks like but it's one
essay question
and then again the resume which uh
you're already preparing a resume for
the mba application so this would just
be an additional
document additional upload of the same
resume
and then the extracurriculars
so um we'll look right now in the
application
and then you you just follow these
instructions in terms of the um
of the document
uh noah any other questions
uh i just wanted to know were there any
uh specific demographic uh
characteristics that you were looking
for i went to the tab itself and it
looks
advised african-americans
anyone who had a diverse experience of
course but it's not particular from a
certain country or nationality like for
example the africa mba program
requires african citizens
is it the same for the p40 fellowship is
there specific uh nationalities or
demographics um no it there is no uh
specific nationality or background we um
we're really looking at diversity in the
broadest sense so it could be any kind
of personal or cultural
experience you've had and
the ultimate
selection is made by lily in terms of
what they feel will meet some of their
diversity goals as a company and
we do you know particularly encourage
applications from ethnic minorities but
the app but the fellowship is open to to
anyone
so let's go on
thank you noha i hope you can stay awake
and listen to the rest of the seminar uh
we're gonna go ahead and um how about
alejandro
hi i just have a quick question i was
wondering if
there's any specific career or sector
experiences that eli lilly is requesting
other candidates
um there there really isn't they it's
sort of like our mba process i mean
we're looking very broadly at
our applicants and and looking at impact
and and there's no particular you don't
have to have any particular industry
experience or
um
and so from year to year you know eli
lilly who's actually been a corporate
sponsor for for many many years um will
take a look at what what they feel they
need in terms of um openings they have
and
diversity goals that they have
anything else thank you very much okay
thank you
okay and uh uh
suleiman i hope i'm not mispronouncing
your name excuse me if i am
uh suleiman
no you did
you did a great job thank you allison um
and for the rest of you guys for uh
setting this up
uh quick question could you kind of just
elaborate on some of the expectations
that you have um for some of the pdf p4d
uh actual you know applicants
um coming into the scholarship as well
as if they are accepted you know some of
the
obligations that you want them to kind
of really um
go through you know once that process
is is done and they're accepted into the
program
right the the first step um suleiman is
to be admitted to the mba program
and i think the criteria for that are
pretty well outlined on our website in
terms of intellectual
uh
vitality and demonstrated leadership
potential so the first thing is to be
admitted to the mba program and then of
the people who are admitted to the mba
program who have also applied to the p4d
fellowship we take those resumes the
additional essay and the
extracurriculars and we
hand them over to lilly
and then they
review them and they make the
determination um
internally
and um
and they base it on you know on those
those three documents they do
invite
candidate finalists to come and
interview so of course the interview is
factored in as well
and um
it's really as simple as that
anything anything
okay
all right thanks see woman okay uh no i
don't know if you have another question
is the piece for you starting this
september as well this fall uh like the
africa or is it a year after
no you you would start your internship
with lily this this year uh this summer
and then you would enroll in stanford in
fall of 2015.
okay okay thank you so much great thank
you no
uh frederick uh how about you did you
have a question
yes well thank you all for uh filling in
a lot of the background that wasn't able
to find on the website my question was
simply approximately how many uh fellows
are selected each year i can imagine it
will vary depending on the corporate
sponsor but just a rough number of how
many are selected and do they all work
at the same site
correct um currently we have one
corporate sponsor who is eli lilly and
they will select one
fellow so for this this current year
it's uh one one fellow who's selected in
future years you know we may have
additional corporate sponsors so you
know if we have two different corporate
sponsors they it would be too shallow so
typically it's one per corporate sponsor
thank you um adolfo
hi uh i'm dolph a moment calling from
tokyo i have a one question for tiffany
and laura and it was if they can please
will you please like comment on what you
believe were the reasons
you were awarded the fellowship
um i'm not sure they would necessarily
know we can pose the question to them
but i'm not sure they'd necessarily know
why they
won it so laura any any um
sense of that
i think that in the same way that you
wouldn't explicitly know
why you were admitted to the mba program
it's similar no one really gives you a
report after the fact
but i would just encourage everyone to
be
the same way as you're going through the
mba application to just be as genuine
and as true to yourself um really not
trying to come up with
an answer that you think
will potentially be the one that they
are looking for but instead just what is
your true story
and
why you truly want this fellowship
program or what you are really looking
to get out of the program and i think
that that will resonate with that
thank you good it's good advice laura
tiffany any any additional thoughts
no i think um i think laura hit the nail
on the head i think that's exactly right
and also too potentially it may have um
i think was probably more than
coincidence with regards to where i was
placed uh in new product planning which
is really like i said an early phase and
strategic
um so maybe they that that was a factor
but again it really it that could
potentially depend on where
they have an opening in a given year
that could potentially affect what type
of candidate they're looking for but
since no one really knows what that is
the best advice is to do exactly kind of
what laura said and just be true to who
you are and express that um and just
follow the prompts
okay
great thank you
how many applicants do you receive a
year
for this fellowship
um it really varies and again uh
there are many people who apply who are
applicants to the mba program but the
actual
candidates who are considered
for the partnership for diversity
fellowship are people who have been
admitted to the mba program so that
they've gotta you know make that first
hurdle so um among those admits it
really varies from year to year
um you know could be
10 could be 20.
you know it's it's sort of in that range
so it's it's not you know it's not
hundreds or anything like that but
it could be you know could be a couple
dozen
um i have a question that uh came in
from uh chong long who's asking
if as part of your
internships tiffany and laura was there
any global experience or uh
were there any uh activities uh abroad
that were was part of your internship
um tiffany let's start with you
yeah i don't i didn't do anything
globally but in part of the forecast
that i was looking at it was important
to understand the different markets
specifically outside of the u.s and how
that would apply but i didn't travel
anywhere but but sometimes and depending
on where you are there is collaboration
with teams in other countries
but it really depends on sort of what
what area you're working in
okay and laura how about you right so
personally i did not travel abroad um i
was based in the headquarters in
indianapolis um but
other individuals and other teams did
travel
to the headquarters on occasion
definitely interface with
teams internationally or also via web
conferences
and things of that nature i do know that
other fellows in the past have
occasionally traveled based off of
opportunities project specific work
and budget and things of that nature i
think it really just depends year to
year
but
it's really you still have that
connection to the full global experience
okay
and for each of you um
what do you think
was the value
um of
doing this experience uh
and then coming to the gsb and enrolling
in school i mean was there any
particular benefits that or that you got
or did it enrich your
gsp experience in any way by doing that
internship first
um laura let's start with you
yeah well i can say that i personally so
far have found it to be invaluable um i
definitely got out of the experience the
few things
i intended and hoped for going into it
and expressed my application so i
definitely got out of it
understanding the contrast between
multiple different big pharma
corporations definitely got the
experience of
the functional expertise really able to
explore the marketing role not just even
in my own department but other areas
within marketing but i think that the
biggest benefit for me was not one that
i
actually anticipated
so i found it really
invaluable to after
being admitted to the gsb actually
having
that additional time to
take a step back and reevaluate and
prioritize what were the specific things
now that
after the additional growth through the
program that i wanted to get out of the
mba program
what were my priorities in the mba
program and where was my focus i would
absolutely of course encourage
anyone to go through that kind of
thought process
over their summer before going to the
mba program but i found it to be
exceptional to have
the 10-month experience within an
organization to really explore that
knowing that i was going into the mba
program i think it's really set me up
for success having all of those things
and the four of my minds going in
do you think it informed how you chose
your classes once you got here
well i think that it definitely will so
far
most of my coursework has been
the foundations and some of the
more explicit laid out
courses but going into the second year
even
i think it will inform some of my
electives
and the approach to also just activities
outside of class and where i want to
focus my attention or things that i want
to develop
okay and tiffany how about you do you
feel the
the doing the internship before coming
to the gsb had any impact on your
experience here
um on the experience yeah so i i feel so
just in general having a broader
set of just life experiences in general
i think is really helpful coming into
the gsb
um and as laura mentioned having that
time to just reflect on what it is i
want to get out of the juice because you
you basically have you know 10 months or
a year to think about that because
you're you are admitted that you're
prior
um so i thought that was really it was a
really unique and special opportunity
and also
even
something as small as being able to
contribute in a different way to class
discussion about a healthcare company
that i would have not have any
have had any idea about um previously
was really helpful i think for me and
also for my classmates to hear from that
perspective as well
because there weren't too many people
who worked directly from a former
company so it was interesting and nice
to be able to contribute in that way but
i think just more generally um and at
the gisb and beyond it was great to be
able to see the
actual different cultures corporate
cultures and works and what that looks
like
it's hard to get a sense of that when
you're on the one you're on the outside
all the time and that's sort of the role
that i had always played before so it
was great to be able to see that because
we they're definitely conversations
about um you know corporate culture and
what does that mean and what are the
implications to
the workforce and um how you know
anything strategy is enacted so it was
great to be able to see that and also uh
to think we were talking about global
opportunities it was good to be able to
think globally
i really hadn't had a chance to
necessarily think about that the
experience was definitely invaluable and
i'm so so glad that i was given the
opportunity and able to do it
great
let's go to more questions coming in so
lindsay
you have your hand raised you're on the
line
hi thanks alison for taking the time to
host this um my question is uh for both
our panelists tiffany and laura
what would you say was your biggest
challenge um with your involvement in
the program what was your biggest area
of growth
okay tiffany
yeah so for me just just learning about
healthcare i i really had no background
so so i would say the first two months
was was difficult it was difficult it
was a foreign language to me um so just
just understanding what was going on and
how it worked were just many of the
terms and especially how the regulatory
environment worked that was the first
time i had ever interacted with anything
like that um so yeah it was a huge
learning curve in the beginning and that
that was a challenge but um yeah i would
say after the first two months it
started to get much better and things
ran a lot more smoothly but yeah it was
it was a fun challenge but definitely a
challenge getting to learn a new
language basically
deep learning curve
okay laura how about you any challenges
you mentioned
yeah i mean i had come from the
pharmaceutical industry so some of the
terms things like that were familiar but
it still definitely was a learning curve
even just transitioning from
manufacturing over to marketing
to me there were cultural differences
modes of operation different processes
all things of that nature but again i i
would second what tiffany has said i
think it's really just
maybe two months and then you're getting
up to speed and really able to
contribute and give back in a
substantial way even by that point and
so i i think it's really just any new
experience a transition a new city and
new everything and you're just coming up
that learning curve
we're coming up on um 45 minutes so i'm
going to ask um both laura and
tiffany
any advice that you would give
our candidates who are considering
applying for the p4d or
any advice for them as mba applicants
even if they decide not to apply for the
fellowship
uh tiffany
yeah so my advice for applying is to
definitely apply i know
these statistics may be intimidating i
was a little intimidated myself when i
found out that there was only going to
be one person selected but um yeah it
never never hurts it just to just apply
so when in doubt definitely apply
especially if you're going through the
process of applying uh through to the to
the gsb
then if you think that you'd be a good
fit please do apply um that's one advice
and with regards to the
the application
that one definitely just think about uh
the
story that you want to tell about who
you are and what you want to accomplish
and make sure that story is consistent
kind of throughout every step of the
application that's sort of the advice
that i give to any prospective student
okay thanks tiffany and i should also
point out that
you can go through the entire selection
process
be offered the fellowship and if you
don't care to take that particular um
opportunity perhaps the the position
they're um offering for some reason is
not of interest to you you can turn it
down and you still have your you know
secure spot in the class you would just
come in fall of 2014 instead of fall of
2015 so there's really no downside to to
applying and doing the extra
essay
and laura any advice for people
considering the fellowship and any
general advice for applicants
well i definitely second the point to
apply i myself had debated about it and
here i am um i would say that if you are
debating if it's something that you want
and that you think would be a great
opportunity for you or a great fit
whatever is holding you back whatever
that limiting belief is let it go and
just apply
and in terms of that application i would
definitely say
just really be true to yourself
i think that
really what works out best is
both the program the mba program and the
fellowship is all about fit it's looking
for that connection on both sides and so
the more genuine you are and uh more
true to yourself the higher the chances
are that that fit is going to be the
right one and that it's going to be
right for you
thank you
so um i'd like to
mention to the audience if you have
further questions that were not answered
today or you have other questions that
you think of
you can either call our office
or send an email
and
our phone number
and
contact information it's at the very
bottom there so uh contact uh there's
our you can send a question in
the email there's our telephone number
so for those of you who are thinking of
applying in round two i'm sure you'll be
working on your applications during the
winter break we wish you best of luck
with that and thank you so much laura
and tiffany for taking the time to share
your experiences
with our applicants
so i will say good luck to everybody and
i will bid you goodbye